liberal leaders being accused of making
self-defense a crime new york city store
worker jose alba is back home after his
bail was lowered but is still facing a
murder charge video showing the
altercation with alba stabbing a man
after being confronted behind the
counter and shoved into a wall crime is
up overall in the city and the nypd
commissioner thinks repeated offenders
could be to blame
we do see a number of people that we are
rearresting for the same offenses over
and over again grand larcenies in many
instances there are either car thefts we
also have shopliftings or multiple
shopliftings and that's basically that
will turn into a robbery if it escalates
into a robbery and we're seeing the same
people over and over again
the spotlight on jose alva's case
putting pressure on liberal leaders to
act new york city mayor adams blaming
extreme ideologies for the public safety
crisis
there's two battles that are happening
in our country in our city right now you
have the far right that states give
everyone a gun no matter what you have
the far left that states everyone that
uses a gun should not be held
accountable
these two groups are not the majority of
americans
and they have actually held our country
in our city hostage
these two groups don't realize their
co-conspirators to the public safety
crisis that we're facing in our city and
country
so judge i'm going to go to you first on
this in terms of the case jose alba's
case the bodega worker um what do you
think his odds are winning this as a
self-defense case good to excellent
great good excellent in fact i think if
they put in the grand jury the grand
jury may say there isn't probable cause
for an indictment in this case look what
you've got is a gang banging career
criminals several state prison
stints who comes in his girlfriend tried
to use a debit card that didn't work uh
she calls her boyfriend he comes in
starts yelling jumps over the counter
knocks the owner over the owner is a you
know doesn't have a record uh and then
pushes him and then he picks him up and
then he pushes him again and uh when he
pulls him to take him out of there
that's when the guy who owns a bodega
grabs the knife to defend himself he
doesn't know where he's going at that
point and the unfortunate part of all of
this is look you've got a guy who
was confronted with a gun here the the
bodega owner several months earlier so
he knows that you know people come in
come in seriously but i got to say one
more thing before you move on i'll be
very quick
i i gotta tell you the more i hear the
sky adams the less i like the guy
absolutely okay what is this um you know
we've got co-conspirators if anybody's a
co-conspirator you are the reason that
the mayor is a co-conspirator here he's
blaming it on the left and he's blaming
it on the right it's your fault it's
your city you're a cop you knew when you
ran you promised that you were going to
take care of gun crimes and murders and
you haven't done a damn thing you won't
go after governor hoka who's running for
office and cash this mail get her to
repeat it repeal it you won't do it with
the husty or with andrea stewart's
cousins in albany you ought to go to
every homicide in this city and hold a
sign up and say because of cashless fail
this murder happened and i won't go on
joey i heard you get him
yeah yeah
number one
the the gruesomeness of being stabbed to
death could be prevented with a gun
that's a much more humane way to defend
yourself all right that's number one
number two if the gun laws weren't so
ridiculous that that a shop owner in a
city prone to violence can't have one a
shotgun to defend himself easily
brandishing that shotgun might have had
that dude turn around and run the other
way and so it's a deterrent in a lot of
ways the fact is you're going to see
more of this because people are not
going to put up with lawlessness they're
not going to be put up with having their
own lives threatened for simply running
a business they're not going to put up
with a group a class of americans who
think they can impose their will on what
they perceive to be the weak because
there's no consequence and how many
people need to needlessly die at knife
point before
d.a start prosecuting people putting
them in jail for smaller crimes i mean
who could have saved that man's life
whoever let him out of jail could have
saved his life by keeping him in jail he
wouldn't have been on the streets to
perform the next act of violence because
obviously slapping someone in the hands
saying you know what you've had rough
breaks in life you shouldn't be put in
this position we're going to let you
back out that doesn't work that doesn't
prevent crime
but it will get you killed if you walk
into a shop into a bodega and threaten
somebody's life that'll get you killed
well greg something that we've been
talking about is the kind of duh moment
about yes these are people who you're
returning to the streets and that's what
the commissioner was acknowledging there
and i love your thoughts on that and
also the point that it was actually the
public that got this guy out on bail
because there was such public outcry in
defense of jose alba that they lowered
the bail to a reasonable amount that he
could actually get himself out of there
so do you see more of a role for people
like us
in making sure that justice is served no
as much as i despise jesse waters
makes me sick to my stomach the fact
that he gets to take fridays off because
his back hurts
when what he's what is he doing he's
sitting while we're here yelling and
screaming he's off having a margarita
but yesterday you know he was the one
that said that you know he said so i got
to give him credit that like we have to
stay on this and get this guy out yeah
and i think a lot of people watch that
you know we're the number one show
in history i believe of all television
shows don't you might want to uh ch fact
check that but i do believe that we are
the number one show in history and and
he said that you know he said we have to
keep we have to keep on this keep on
this and lo and behold you have it on
the on the new york post but this is the
you think about this this is the thing
that
in an alternative universe it will
infuriate you what if there was no tape
exactly
they would have taken them the stabbed
suspect he would be a martyr there would
be a mural
there would be a march
there would be riots and the bodega
worker would be portrayed as a monster
as a racist yes
but thankfully this is why i mean i'm
like i'm not
i am now so pro surveillance body cam
put it everywhere because if you didn't
see this you know exactly the kind of
narrative you know what happened biden
would have spoke out against this bodega
guy he would have said that bodega guy
he's got to pay
look what he did to this innocent this
poor he was just getting his life back
together
yeah and he gets stabbed
by a monster
katie i'd love to get your thoughts the
idea that there was bail at all for jose
alba is atrocious given the kind of
criminals they let out with no bail and
the fact that he's being charged at all
in the situation when there is video
is absolutely ridiculous and it will
make his life much harder uh in the
future you know most people especially
people working in crime ridden areas um
like new york city would rather be
judged by 12 than carried by six yeah
and it's a lot easier to do that when
you live in an area where you're allowed
to defend yourself with a firearm and so
for mayor adams to come out in support
of this bodega
worker good thing but he has done
nothing to offer any kind of deterrence
to these criminals who aren't afraid of
the system they're not afraid of the
cops they're not afraid of the
prosecutors obviously because they're
running back through the system as that
police officer was saying so the only
thing they're going to be afraid of is
self-defense and the mayor of new york
city is preventing people from being
allowed to defend their own lives from
people who walk in and know that there
will be no consequences for them because
the mayor and everybody else
are on the side not of the bodega
workers trying to make an honest living
but the criminals in the city who are
running the show they do overcharge on
potato chips though let's be clear well
no
they deserved it stay right there we
have breaking news about elon musk's
twitter deal next i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now